Instagram
hello Mr President
uh Mr President I I uh it's very nice to
meet you I'm Matt Murray the
editor-in-chief of the journal we're
very honored that you've taken the time
to join us at this incredibly
challenging moment
we appreciate it more than we could say
I want to note for the audience here
that We're translating in real time so
you and I have a bit of a lag but we'll
do the best we can I also want to make
sure to welcome our audiences on wsj.com
Twitter and YouTube to the program
and again thank you sir and I believe uh
you have some opening remarks you'd like
to start us off with
um
please thank you so much
hello again
I'm very grateful for the opportunity to
speak before you now we are going
through difficult times
in flux
we still
have to do what we have to do
and there won't be the same life as we
had before
[Music]
[Music]
and it's not just about the life of our
states the companies and business and
the global corporations they have to
play a very important part more
important than many countries Russia has
started a full-scale war against Ukraine
we all know about that we hope that it
would not be dead and we hope that the
global business would not
starts cooperating
and well
follow everyone's values
the sovereignty of Ukraine and the
preparedness of our partners to help us
this is very important and we are very
grateful for that
see that Russia bit by bits becomes more
and more isolated as a country and the
business
step-by-step starts understanding that
international law has to be honored
[Music]
agreements have to be honored and what's
happening in the global economy can be
happening only if you respect yourself
and others and do not limit the freedom
of others all of this is not just about
Russia
the worst aggressor in the world it's
about everyone because we have to
understand
that that has to be respected we see how
various parties react
God forbid they start another aggression
we have to see how the world
reacts to this
other wolves have to be prevented
also what do we need for this what do we
need right now
right now not later but first and
foremost first and foremost the
aggressor has to be isolated
economically full complete economic
isolation and that will allow Ukraine to
fight to defend our rights and
we have to restore everything which was
destroyed by the war by Russian
aggression we have to see that war is
not allowing
uh to ruin anything in the future
firstly
what was clear before the meeting today
I can see that Mr Graf the head of
Russians bear Bank isn't here I'm glad
that she was included on the sanctions
list on the part of the UK
to this day we seize Burbank as a member
of your club that is surprising to me
how is that possible
that is I'm sure a misunderstanding
I think that would be just thing to do
that would be not just a gesture
because if any companies remain in the
Russian Market that means you are
directly supporting that war machine the
terrorist Russian Federation War Machine
via Texas via placing projects with them
because many of the companies still
carrying on in Russia traditionally
you're counting the profits and losses
however
working with the terrorist states on the
part of Britain
that results in
tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands of millions of losses in the
end because
the political chaos
and leaving the Russian Market that is a
must
second of course that's supporting
Ukraine we all know what losses were
suffered by our state through the war
from the start of the war Russia has
blocked our ports all of our ports
and part of the export was blocked
that of course completely stopped that
part of our economy
thousands of Enterprises were stopped by
state and private Enterprises
so looking at Ukraine's losses
that's around 600 billion dollars and
that is not just for the state budget we
need a support of our economy up to
seven billion and many companies
um of your CEO Council have contributed
to UNICEF have contributed to the Red
Cross and other International
organizations I'm very grateful for it
thank you so much that was a great hope
however the costs
that does not always reach Ukrainian
citizens so we need to help our citizens
for example via these bonds instruments
and supporting our Central Bank because
we are paying are we paying citizens
using our Central Bank and I'm grateful
that you are helping us but helping us
you're helping yourself first and
foremost because we need stability we
need freedom
and thirdly
those that doubted our Victory the
victory
will be ours we will rebuild everything
that was destroyed and you can
contribute to our rebuilding to use the
opportunities your companies building
offices and Care bringing our companies
your companies to Ukraine for the whole
of Ukraine and into cave and to you will
get access in our country to our 40
million plus Market one of the largest
markets in the European Union as you
know
the taxes
cuts for Import and Export and um we're
grateful too Japan the US other markets
our partners our qualified experts
we have very convenient Logistics for
important export to Europe and energy
sources including nuclear and it
certainly would be a benefit for
organizations working in Ukraine we have
shown the heroism in defense defense of
our joint freedom and we believe in our
Victory will demonstrate the same
examples and locate the best conditions
in Europe for Investments for you it
would be good to invest in our state all
of that
will happen
and that will be a part of the New Order
in Europe and your contributes to the
global increase in economy and what's do
each of us in each of you and us require
each of us in Ukraine and I'm sure this
is what we need
maybe I was speaking for too long but
I'm very certain of it
glory to Kane
[Applause]
thank you I I don't think you've spoke
for too long but you anticipated about
half of my questions
um
so let me uh respond to some of what you
just said and let me start by asking you
um simply to step back a minute the
human toll in Ukraine obviously has been
devastating and I'm sure is is the most
devastating aspect
of the war
what's the state of and damage for the
economy and the infrastructure and how
bad is that right now
thank you
if I heard the question correctly
technician because we had technical
moments I do apologize because what was
the amount of losses in Ukraine
economically was that the question
yeah what's the how do you assess the uh
the damage to the economy and the
infrastructure for your country right
now how bad are things
as I mentioned
now we're talking that previously we
were talking about 600 billion dollars
in losses the infrastructure was hit
um residential quarters
Enterprises and many things were
actually new built that were destroyed
and
um
the time I was in office around three
years to be honest we have built a lot a
lot of various things and restored lots
of things we had ambitious goals and a
very good team luckily we still have the
team so I'm sure the issues will be
resolved so 600 billion that is just an
estimate primary as estimates we don't
know everything in what towns something
was destroyed by the Russian Federation
for example
Maria pool was raised to the ground
and I was a beautiful town
and there were many factories including
the steel
um out of style Factory and
partially well now the constant fighting
there so I think that variable as a city
is completely destroyed raised to the
ground how much has to be restored there
so many towns have to be restored and
um
I don't think anyone in Europe was
actually calculating because 5 million
people were living in the city I think
it's a very complex task to put an
estimate on it but I'm sure after
Victory we will do everything quite fast
and Ukraine will be even more beautiful
of course we have experts we have clever
people to work on that and currently I'm
sure will be lots of new technologies
diploids and will be able to restore it
all
uh sir when you say victory
for those of us uh following the war
closely there seems to have been uh some
shift uh Ukraine has obviously uh stayed
very heavily in the fight Russia's had
many challenges and problems
of late we've seen a few incursions into
Russia we've seen some Russian ships uh
come down new weapons are flowing into
Ukraine all the time while the Russians
are facing challenges so
when you say victory
what do you mean what is victory for you
now and how has that changed from the
beginning of the war
thank you
to restore the territorial Integrity
it's our number one task
that is important to push onto Russian
Federation to the borders before the
24th of February and of course
territorially
um well we hope that uh Crimea will be
part of Ukraine and we'll be able to do
it
we will be able to show what we can do
the way we can of course we will move to
the Diplomatic route after the war will
be finished diplomatically
that's why we have to stand strong
and we need sanction support from our
partners and support to his arms and
maximum would be to restore our
territorial integrity and that perhaps
will then move to the different format
of negotiations I believe I don't know
how long that would
um be going on before I have no
guarantees in this regards
but I am confident of our people
confident of our army and I'm confident
that Victory will be ours and we can see
now that we are not retweeting as of
today there are already new stages
and we have already gaining ground
and we are pushing away the Russian army
we're awaiting to receive the Munitions
the arm equipments on our part and in
some charity we're moving forward we're
advancing not a step back
to be clear you're it sounds like you're
saying your goal really right now is to
push them off all territory including
Crimea is that right
that will happen the goal of Ukraine is
to restore our territorial integrity
that's what I am saying I understand
that it's not possible to get everything
immediately we need certain steps to
stop the wall first and subsequently
diplomacy will kick in today it's
important to do stage one the main stage
we will do that I is stopping Russian
advance and we will do stage two to the
maximum so that Russia to leave our
territory so and the third stage would
be to restore Ukraine's territorial
Integrity to the maximum extent possible
nevertheless it's possible to do to
restore territorial Integrity where
possible and find some human compromise
some dial log where possible
using words and not using arms that's
where Ukraine will be doing it showing
our strong position as an equal partner
in the dialogue
but I wanna I wanna talk a little more
on the dialogue but to be clear when you
talk about about
your goals and your dialogue is there
any
settlement possible in your mind if it
ends the war
that
doesn't Retreat to the February 23rd
borders do you have to retreat to the
February 23rd borders
before you have any settlement at least
or further
yeah
yes
ceasefire we have to see the wish for
the ceasefire on the part of the Russian
Federation so far we are not seeing that
they if they really want to do the C5
ceasefire they have to do it
so
here from the Russian Federation just
discuss the contact line the donbass for
several years but we keep working and
they're saying we're agreeing something
then they're breaching the agreement the
issue is that
we even now we're talking about
ceasefire
in Maria pool
yeah and freeing the civilian
populations
and evolving the U.N in helping doing
that nevertheless they're still fighting
they're still bombarding and shooting so
we need some ceasefire we need a
breather
and they also yeah they were bombing us
and various bombs including the bands
types of bombs and that intensive
bombing on the part of Russia carries on
intensifies unfortunately
I can stay the facts for an hour and a
day on end
and I have many
breaches that I could enumerate
so I cannot sit at the moment I cannot
say who would stick to the agreement
and that's it that's why we're seeing
the ceasefire only when we will have the
leaders
dialogue leaders of countries President
Putin
and then perhaps ceasefire will be
happening
otherwise
and then we will negotiate with him
person to person
and agree obligations as to ceasefire
and on that day we would then start
believing in that but the ceasefire
regime shall mean that there is no fire
and Russian troops will stand where they
are and that might lead to a frozen
conflict we are not agreeing to Frozen
conflict
there are two documents that had to be
signed and that was not agreed to follow
two that would be not just paper
agreement so basically zombies was a
frozen conflict I I'm against
the documents as to Minsk agreement they
breached them on the 24th of February
and the Russian leader said that in
public and they started we started
understanding and that is a full-scale
Invasion that is the war so they left a
Minsk agreements they broke it off and
the basically it's a diplomatic Quagmire
and Ukraine is not going to fall for it
again
in my office me being a president
you have no contact right now with the
Russians
our negotiating groups are communicating
at the level of negotiating group
constituents
um
talking
about the preparation of the summit
between the country's leaders
so but they are in communication I can
openly say
I don't believe in such negotiations too
much I think it's important to keep
talking
but until the president of the Russian
Federation would sign or do some
official
um appeal I do not see any weight in
such negotiations
there's been a notable step up uh in
commitments from the West in the last
few weeks here in Britain today I know
Boris Johnson spoke to your Parliament
and the British are offering 500 million
pounds in additional Aid
the U.S has been offering more Aid and
you've welcomed secretary blinken and
Austin and speaker Pelosi
you've obviously been pushing the West
are you satisfied at this point that
you're getting
the support that you need is it enough
or what more do you want
simply cannot be enough
we cannot afford
to pleads for various uh Foods or other
supports or support towards Munitions
with arms on the other hand I have to be
openly thanking everyone for any help
because we are fighting we need help I
am indeed very grateful for what we've
got
and of course some is not reaching us
yet and I understand that because
obviously Sometimes some communities are
promising and not sending the aid
s
well okay you say you're not gonna help
and that's fine
okay I cannot Demand anymore
however if you promise something if
you're a real leader if you believe
you're a global leader then you have to
demonstrate this leadership however
indeed the tempo of support is
increasing now and I really have to
thank Britain and the US
and the European Union
and they are saying that Ukraine has
United the European Union and I'm very
pleased that I've done something for
uniting the European Union I'm
pleased that uh
it's not it's not it's not about bad
achievements unfortunately the price for
that is very high that is war and that's
why
we would like to unite together
not at such cost
I I feel like I have to say you've
United them and maybe they'll let you in
eventually but uh
um
I
one question on the west and then I want
to come back I know your time is short
you know when secretary Austin was there
last week he said that the aim of the
United States now is to actively degrade
Russia's capability to wage war like
this ever again which seemed an
escalation
of how the U.S views it and the Russians
have responded that this is now for them
a war with the West at least that's what
they've said
so amid the destruction in Ukraine are
you at risk of becoming
sort of a proxy Battleground between
Russia and the West in a way that
inflicts more damage
I don't think it's quite just
towards our people and Ukrainian Army to
all of our people that were defensing
people of various walks of life but
they are really
fighting I say that this is not uh
correct not just because it's very clear
the information the internal policy and
it's the same
idea of the Russian Federation that was
his idea
we in our territory we are fighting but
on their territory
there is something that people only had
on TV
and they indeed are not taking any care
of their people hundreds of thousands of
people they were simply pushing forward
as Canon folder for us to kill them and
their lives they're taking our lives we
simply are defending our country and we
definitely understand that their army
is simply numerous simply more people
but they have to drown Us in the blood
of our soldiers
they have lots of people and they are
not
um taking any pity on their people
they're not counting them and um their
army is not modern at all it's not
adequate
and they are not able to say to their
Community to their country that they
lost
to our Unity to our modern Army so their
army lost their army was not prepared
was not ready and that could be a
complete Fiasco for them and we can be
flattened by Rockets we can be burned
however
from the point of military tactics they
could not win over us and won't be able
to and I have to say that Russia
is talking with the United West that's
that's why they are saying what they are
saying they thought that they'll take
care of in five days
but that was a test
still the fact is the fact we are
fighting we know how to fight because
the war in our territory was going on
for eight years and they
have heard about the war only on TV
that's all but we are not being proud
about that we we just believe that we
can
push Russia back I simply want to
save the people because
something that can be
a source of pride has to remain
thank you sir I'm going to just give you
two questions and let you get back to
your work but um you mentioned in your
remarks the time when the war ends and
the time that will one day come for
rebuilding Ukraine
you're among other things that are in a
room here full of uh business executives
when that time comes who who and how
should pay for rebuilding Ukraine
and that includes should the Russians
pay reparations
but when you look ahead to that time
what what will you need
yeah
pain reparations yes Russian has to pay
for win
it must
seems to me
we are fighting Russia but we are also
fighting for the values
of the whole civilized worlds that is
the whole absolute truth
that is the truth and I'm saying that we
are
our people we are getting all the
signals from the Western countries
Russia will have to pay reparations we
know it clearly
that is
a great Beast with a great appetite and
today we're talking about economic
problems in their country
still they would go down the route they
dream of more territory
that would be under their influence and
they understand
I went uh that wants more influence
but that's why they won't stop they will
want more and more they would want the
Baltic states then they want Latvia
Lithuania Estonia
as it is shown today
um the Russian Federation simply does
not understand
the difference
they would be Burning Bridges that's
what happens with us we thought there
were brothers the best relations that we
had with we had families together we
were studying Russian using Russian we
had many things in common and today in
Ukraine you would not find any people
that would say that we have something
left in common with them
this is what we have and this is what
was so it was we still have Russian
speakers but they have suffered more
than anyone else of you in the territory
the wires dozens of rockets destroying
their towns of the Russian speakers in
Ukraine for the most towns
where the majority of the population
were Russian speakers exactly there and
those people lived there
some of them died
so that's why
attitude to everything Russian is very
difficult they've destroyed all that
relationship themselves that's why
continue with my thought those that say
today that
um
that it's only economic relations
talking about various things I don't
want to discuss this this is not
important no one feels that once the
year it seems to you that you have a
business with such and such Russian
company it seems soon that they are
paying money on time it seems to you
that is a profitable business but one
day just one day you wake up to realize
that rocket is flying towards you from
Russia and everything changes
all of that just
goes to pot goes to hell all of your
mentions of any business with them
included it's not possible to do
business with someone who tomorrow
would simply
instead of um payment
that's why we are protecting our joint
values and restoration of Ukraine
talking about who has to do it I think
that Russia must
and who needs Ukraine and who
understands that we are defending the
whole of Europe I believe that the whole
of Europe in this
sense has to understand this and help us
um restoring our state restoring various
Industries and yes of course coming to
our markets and
that's apart from your support is very
needed
today companies live in the Russian
Market you're very welcome the Ukrainian
we have 40 million people of course they
have a 150 million but nevertheless our
people are very worthy and they are
defending Europe and we lost many people
unfortunately the war is still going on
and that means we might lose some more
and two
fill that bridge
it has to be the support from your
punches so I hope just everyone
understands that
oh thank you Mr President if I may
um your passion is obviously manifest
for everybody watching you here I think
those of us watching from afar
have a real sense of the devastation of
the war but of course
you're living it there are things many
things we can't understand so if I could
ask
lastly amid all of the things that
you're seeing and experiencing every day
do you mind
um
telling us a little bit about what are
the images and experiences
that are most staying with you
that are most Vivid or most horrible
from this time
yeah
I don't know whether
yeah
it seems to me that to understand this
one probably needs to be here and to
experience that
Maybe
because
something to do
with everything that is alive
we were killing
they they're army people they were
fighting they were killing our civilians
so armed people would
uh to kill civilians they were killing
me
it was simply shocking I was in shock to
what they did with real living people
I'm sorry I'm sorry
because people are dining people around
the table and it's difficult to discuss
this there were cutting
arms and legs are cutting heads off they
were binding people's arms and legs they
were cutting
extremities I've never seen that
anywhere ever
not even in films
and when we saw terrorist acts when we
saw when people were their throats were
slit by militants terrorists in various
terrorist organizations we have seen a
lot of that
but this is not the way it was it wasn't
like that they were
torturing them
keeping them for several days
not feeding them and then torturing them
in a beastly way I simply never ever
seen any anything like this in the
worlds I'm still in shock
that in such a culture and in such a
religion
as Christianity yeah
you know Russia is
the biggest
[Music]
Orthodox state in the world I was simply
surprised that
people claiming to be Believers in God
still not being able to see God in this
way
that was the biggest shock for me
oh
well president zielinski
um we couldn't appreciate more you're
taking time tonight amid everything else
that's happening in your country and the
generosity that you've shown us and the
Candor which we've shared your feelings
I know I speak for uh everybody and all
of our audience here when we say how
much we appreciate it how grateful we
are and to thank you for being with us
and
for what you're doing there in Kiev so
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you so much each and every one of
you
[Applause]
thank you
I want to thank our audiences too on
wsj.com Twitter and YouTube and uh I'm
gonna turn it back